Teď, co jsme prošli všechny prvky VQE, pojďme
shrnout, co jsme se naučili, a podívat se, jak to kvantový počítač provede.
Začínáme s chytře zvoleným referenčním stavem, parametrizovaným circuit,
počátečním výběrem parametrů a Hamiltonianem.
Tyto předáme našemu kvantovému počítači.
Než může být Hamiltonián proveden na ansatz stavu,
potřebujeme provést klasické předpracování circuit
tak, aby byl čitelný kvantovým hardwarem, v procesu zvaném transpilace.
Je také důležité co nejvíce využít
architekturu qubitů v reálném hardwaru pro dosažení nejlepších výsledků.
Tyto procesy jsou často řešeny automaticky, takže my
nemusíme explicitně znát konektivitu qubitů,
věrnosti gate a tak dále.
Teď je úkolem změřit výsledný stav
a odhadnout střední hodnotu, která bude dále
optimalizována klasickým optimalizátorem.
Toto měření se provádí rotací měřicí báze
a následným kombinováním výsledků měření pro získání střední hodnoty.
Tento parametrizovaný výsledek je pak předán
do klasického optimalizátoru, který najde nové parametry pro stav.
Pak se proces opakuje.
Klasické předpracování vytvoří nový parametrizovaný circuit
a aplikujeme stejný Hamiltonián jako předtím.
Všimni si, že v celém procesu VQE měníme pouze stavy
prostřednictvím parametrů, které se stále více blíží základnímu stavu.
Opakujeme to, dokud nejsme spokojeni s výsledkem.
A to je vše.
Jmenuji se Victoria Lipinska a toto byl kurz variantního kvantového eigensolverus.